for the latest on this icy forecast
let's go to meteorologist Rob Ellis from
our Chicago station wbbm-tv good morning
Rob good morning and it looks like that
cold air now the coldest of the air is
going to be into New England and we do
have most of the country now below
freezing but that pattern may change
soon it's not gonna happen tonight
potentially the coldest night expected
right now for tonight into tomorrow
early morning where the temperatures are
likely to be in the single digits or
even below zero for New England for
Northeast and even into the East Coast
however we could see a warm-up as we get
into Sunday afternoon and evening with
many locations finally getting above
freezing it will be a nice change from
the pattern that we've had in place high
temperatures on Sunday could get into
the 30s and 40s for locations that
haven't seen that temperature so warm
since Christmas since before Christmas
the problem is it comes with this a
chance for some rain a little wintry mix
and yes even some snow as the system
moves East into Sunday and Monday
unfortunately that wintry mix is going
to cause some problems and even some
storms in the Gulf Coast Anthony
meteorologist Rob Elish Ellis from our
Chicago station wbbm-tv Bob Rob thank
you very much